[Musique]
j'avais mal à masquer est un général ce
qui nous intéresse nous c'est comme l'a
dit le président c'est de comprendre
vraiment de comprendre et pas de 2,2 de
faire un procès y compris au cabinet de
conseil c'est pas du tout notre peau
notre notre sujet c'est de comprendre
pourquoi
nous utilisons autant d'argent public
parce que c'est des millions quand même
d'argent public en faisant appel à des
cabinets de deux conseils alors que sur
bien des sujets nous avons quand même
une administration dans notre pays qui
est en capacité
d'apporter son intelligence on reprend
la loi l'homme l'exposé des motifs et
l'étude d'impact de la loi l'homme
expliquez-moi pourquoi
il y a été nécessaire il fut nécessaire
pardon d'avoir recours à un cabinet
privé pour la rédaction de l'exposé des
motifs et de l'étude d'impact de de
cette loi d'ailleurs le conseil d'état a
relevé des incohérences sur sûr
[Musique]
sur ces textes qui ont été produits par
ces cabinets conseils et puis par
ailleurs juste avant vous on nous avons
auditionné le cabinet est si un
partenaire ce qui
aurait été missionné pour la
transformation de la drh des services du
premier ministre afin nous dit-on de
repenser l'organisation de ces services
les processus et le positionnement des
avis des entités des services du premier
ministre donc est-ce que
vous avez été sollicité ou informer sur
cette prestation
si oui comment s'est-elle déroulée et
quelles ont été ses conséquences sur le
secrétaire le secrétariat général du
gouvernement
donc j'ai parlé de la loi là mais je
pourrais aussi parler de du ministre de
la transition écologique qui a décidé de
publier une contre étude d'impact
réalisée par la multinationale de
conseil le boston consulting group bcg
qui porte sur l'ensemble des mesures
prises en matière de lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique depuis le début
du quinquennat donc est ce que vous
pensez qu'il est acceptable que le
ministère de l'a36 transition écologique
court circuite des institutions
qualifiées et compétentes mise en place
afin aux fins d'évaluer l'action
gouvernementale le haut conseil pour le
climat qui a été créée quand même par le
président de la république emmanuel
macron ne pouvait-il pas réaliser une
telle publication nous nous retrouvons
avec une appréciation du haut conseil
pour le climat une appréciation du
conseil économique social et
environnemental
une appréciation du conseil national de
la transition écologique mais justement
donc était-il en portant alors que nous
avons déjà eu il y avait tous ces avis
était il opportun de faire d'avoir
recours à au cabinet que j'ai cités pré
pré pré pré s'est précédemment donc
voilà c'est ça nous ne te de sujet on le
fait de procès à personnes qui avouent
ni au cabinet où je le dis souvent je
suis pas pour licencier les milliers de
personnes qui travaillent dans des cas
bien conseil privé c'est pas du tout mon
sujet le sujet c'est un la question de
l'utilisation de l'argent public de la
question de la souveraineté de notre
pays quand même
rapporteur
sur pourquoi ont recours à des cabinets
de conseil donc je g j'ai essayé
d'esquisser des cas de figure dans
lesquelles ça me semble légitime je dois
dire que j'aurais pu dire aussi que je
pense que le recours au cabinet de
conseil saad dessine assez bien
bon baromètre des forces et des
faiblesses de l'administration
je crois honnêtement que dans le champ
de l'expertisé juridique
globalement l'administration est bien
armé on sait faire des textes parfois on
nous reproche d'en faire trop ces
jeux sont faits sur berck sur un réflexe
de jeu reste à vrai dire de faire trop
de textes mais mais en tout cas
l'administration produit du texte ça
c'est sûr et donc en principe je vous
rejoins complètement pour considérer que
ya pas tellement de raison d'avoir
besoin de conseils
juridiques alors après il ya des
exceptions l'agent judiciaire de l'état
a fait appel à des des avocats pour
défendre l'état devant les juridictions
judiciaires c'est très spécifique mais
globalement et moi je dois dire enfin
voila mon expérience personnelle de
juristes quand même je n'ai jamais fait
appel
après une prestation extérieure d'emblée
différentes affectations en tant qu' en
tant que je reste alors vous vous citer
un cas de figure qui est une qui semble
être une exception à ce principe puisque
effectivement un cabinet a participé à
la rédaction d'une étude d'impact moi je
ne connais pas c'était en 2018 et puis à
vrai dire les ministères sont en moi je
suis pas tour de contrôle du recours à
des cabinets de conseil je crois juste
je sais pas ce qu'il en était pour
l'exposé des motifs je crois ce que ce
qui me semble c'est qu'une étude
d'impact
compte tenu des rubriques qui doit être
enseigné notamment la capacité à d'abord
à montrer de quelles étaient les
alternatives possibles au choix qui a
été fait et on évaluer les conséquences
économiques sociales
j'aurais dit que bien sûr mais pas que
fait que je je ça me semble pas aberrant
pour le coup que la participation à la
réflexion sur une étude d'impact et pu
être en partie externalisée sais pas
c'est pas la rédaction même même si ça
peut être que c'est arrivé aussi un jeu
voilà mais c'est pas c'est quand même
pas complètement la production normative
c'est aussi la réflexion sur est-ce
qu'on avait besoin de la loi est-ce
qu'il fallait agir comme ça où est ce
qu'il y avait une autre solution est ce
que c'est ça on rentre dans le champ de
la politique là les choix politiques oui
alors c'est une autre des questions que
vous vous posez
qui est de savoir voilà jusqu'où va
jusqu'où les choix politiques ce ne sont
finalement qu'à la fin que
enfin sont préemptés ou pas par le les
travaux des consultants mois va mon
expérience personnelle mais encore une
fois c'est j'ai du mal à y croire ça
enfin en tout cas
que après de façon un peu insidieuse on
s'habitue à être alimentés et y compris
par des cabinets de conseil qui parfois
applique un peu la même solution à des
choses qui sont
n'adapte pas suffisamment leur
production où
je disais tout à l'heure c'est
intéressant d'avoir un regard extérieur
c'est intéressant pourvu que ce regard
extérieur se soit pas toujours le même
et qu'il regarde pas tous les objets de
la même façon donc ça c'est une question
de réflexion sur la diversité aussi des
prestataires hockey auquel on peut faire
appel pas que les gros aussi les petits
voilà mes mais c'est un peu une autre
question que de savoir si dans le champ
de la production normative qui est un
peu le coeur de métier de
l'administration on ferait trop appel à
des ça je crois honnêtement que c'est
pas le feront de façon concrète dans
votre réponse et ce qu'il faut en
conclure que le secrétaire général du
gouvernement n'a pas été consultée dans
le livre
l'initiative du ministère qui a fait
confier cette étude d'impact à un
cabinet privé je peux enfin je n'étais
pas là mais je n'y a aucune raison mais
c'est enfin
le secrétariat général du gouvernement
assemble à la fin l'étude d'impact donc
avant l'envoi au conseil d'état puis
suit son évolution au fil de l'évolution
du texte avant le dépôt au parlement
mais on est là la réponse est claire
[Musique]
posez le choix des mots
ça pose un cadre et en l'occurrence un
cadre politique quand il s'agit de
l'exposé des motifs d'une loi donc je
pense qu'on peut assez aisément
comprendre qu'un certain nombre de
personnes dans l'administration parmi
les politiques ont pu être choqués
lorsque ces produits
7,7 parce que la formation mais est
arrivé selon laquelle des exposés des
motifs d'une loi avait été rédigé avec
le concours en nous at on dit ou par un
cabinet privé en l'occurrence sur la loi
l'homme
ça a été d'autant plus étonnant sans
parler du fait d'être choqué d'autant
plus étonnant que la responsabilité
de la rédaction de l'exposé des motifs
était celle d'une ministre qui connaît
l'administration qu'il n'est pas une
personne qui découvre l administration
qui est une ministre qui connaît
l'ensemble des administrations avec les
préfets de région était préfète de
région directrice de cabinet de du
ministère de l'écologie et qu'elle
connaît le privé aussi pour avoir exercé
des fonctions dans le privé et notamment
dans le domaine des transports donc cet
étonnement il n'est pas il pas justement
étonnant il me semble assez légitime
dans ce que vous venez de nous exposer
je peux parfaitement comprendre et ça
nous éclaire beaucoup le fait qu'il n'y
a pas une tour de contrôle sur la façon
dont les administrations en creux un peu
comme vous l'avez dit finalement mon
trousseau leur manque de 2,2 de
ressources mais comme il comme comme une
entreprise privée comme une collectivité
territoriale
si on fait appel à l'extérieur c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas la ressource en
interne et au contraire les domaines
dans lesquels on ne fait pas appel à la
ressource extérieure
c'est parce qu'on a ressources en
interne et fort heureusement
l'administration française est
extrêmement bien pourvues de avec ce
qu'il faut par exemple en matière de
compétences de juriste mais en dépit de
l'absence de cette tour de contrôle est
ce que oui ou non vous pouvez ou c'est
peut-être pas votre rôle nous dire
aujourd'hui si un ministre peut
s'aventurer
en l'état actuel des choses à faire
appel à un cabinet conseils pour la
rédaction de l'exposé des motifs du mois
voire pour la rédaction d'un d'un projet
de loi ou est-ce que cet événement quand
même tiré la sonnette d'alarmé effet que
dans la culture
gouvernementale de manière générale on a
compris que faire cela n'était pas
anodin et un ministre ne s'y
aventurerait pas sauf à être couvert
si vous permettez juste prolongé un tout
petit peu la question en sur un aspect
très concret en vous demandant de madame
la secrétaire générale si vous avez
connaissance d'autres interventions de
cabinet de conseil dans la rédaction
d'étude d'impact d'un point de vue très
concret mais la question est plus
général
alors non j'ai pas j'ai pas connaissance
de du tout de recours à des cabinets de
conseils pour rédiger des études
d'impact je redis que c'est pas la même
chose et moi je
j'avoue que je suis pas plonger dans
détails sur ce précédent qui amène à mon
sens et unique d'ailleurs donc ça montre
bien que ce n'est pas du tout une
culture ce n'est pas culturel chez nous
et et moi j'en avais entendu parler
comme portant bien sur l'étude d'impact
est pas l'exposé des motifs et je redis
que l'étude d'impact c'est c'est quand
même autre chose que la production d'un
texte normatif c'est la réflexion sur
des impacts y compris socio économique
et donc une appréciation qui peut
relever de techniques qui sont pas
toutes internaliser voilà donc je alors
que les exposer un exposé des motifs
effectivement est là pour le coup en
tant que j'en ai vu un certain n'ont
passé depuis que je suis arrivé au sgg
franchement c'est sûr c'est un objet
politique et là on le relit en réunion
de relecture avant que ça parte au
conseil d'état si jamais il y avait eu
un moment donné quelqu'un qui était
intervenu pour proposer une des briques
de cet exposé des motifs en tout état de
cause et encore une fois je pense que
plus personne à ce réflexe ça serait
retravaillé
et le c'est là que je disais que moi je
gérard enfin j'ai jamais eu l'occasion
de me dire ah ça je ce sens qu'une
décision politique est en fait
complètement influencé par un livre à 20
d'un cabinet de conseil moi je sens au
contraire que la pâte politique sur un
exposé des motifs elle et elle est
majeure et d'ailleurs c'est jeudi que le
sgg on a vu beaucoup mais le sgg sur
l'exposé des motifs autant it il est le
gardien du temple sur le fait qu'il faut
qu'il ya un exposé des motifs que chacun
des articles soient bien décrit etc mais
on n'a pas là on n'a pas la main parce
que précisément c'est le politique qui
tient la main alors que sur la rédaction
de la loi elle-même il arrive assez
souvent que léger propose une rédaction
parce que ça passe la rampe
constitutionnel ou donc donc je crois
que c'est vraiment pour le coup je peux
comprendre l'émoi que ça a pu susciter
mais je pense que c'est assez
exceptionnel que je ne suis pas sûr
encore une fois que ça n'ait pas porté
sur des bouts d'étude d'impact qis où ça
me choque pas en réalité qui puisse y
avoir eu un apport extérieur et que dans
ce champ là du droit et de la production
normative on n'est vraiment pas guetté
par le risque que les cabinets de
conseil prennent près de la main